So i mean here's an example of
just showing a binary image.
Okay, where you've got a circuit with
some leads that are connecting it and
some of those leads have shown up well
and some of them show not so well.
Or maybe some of these things are noise
and you want to get rid of them, and
here of course this is a notional
version of a binary image where you've
got ones and zeros.
So binary image analysis is
used in all sorts of things.
We're just showing you sort of document
inspection, but parts inspection.
So you've got a part and it's supposed
to have particular property to it and
you don't want to make sure there
are any holes that shouldn't be there or
the holes that are supposed to be there,
are there.
Mostly for two dimensional stuff,
also manufacturing.
You have some idea of what the images
are supposed to look like, but
it's basically, where is there stuff and
where is there not stuff,
is what matters.
And so
you can think of those as binary images.
And of course, document processing,
where the where basically,
if you think of it as just black
ink on a white background,
it might be very fine, but there's,
there's not really supposed to be grey.
Now those of you that
know about anti-aliasing,
that has to do with limited resolution.
We're not going to talk about that.
We're just going to talk
about sort of binary images.